prime minister a year ago you said there
would be a border in the irish sea and
i'll quote you over my dead body and
here
we both are there is a border in the
irish sea were you lying
when you said there wouldn't be one or
did you not understand
the treaty that you signed over brexit i
think that the
treaty we signed i signed is perfectly
reasonable i don't think that the
interpretation or application of the
protocol is is sensible or pragmatic and
what i'm hearing from our friends in the
eu
is that they uh they understand the
strength of our feeling on this and
they understand why a government might
want to protect the
the territorial integrity of the uk plus
the
the the uk's internal market it matters
about being a trusted partner around the
world and president macron said today
he wants a reset but only if you keep
your word on the brexit deal so will you
here and now
publicly recommit to the northern
ireland protocol
i think that the protocol can work if
it's sensibly
applied but at the moment there is it's
not just a question of chill meats or
or sausages there are all kinds of
impediments being
constructed and we need to sort it out i
think we can sort it out
but i think we can sort it out but it's
up to our eu friends and partners to
understand that
you know we will do whatever it takes
and
you know there is some misunderstanding
does that mean whatever it takes
that you won't honor the the protocol
i think if the protocol continues to be
applied in
uh this way then uh we will
obviously not hesitate to invoke article
16 as i've said before don't forget
the eu themselves invoked article 16 in
in january to disapply the protocol so
they can stop the movement of vaccines
uh from from the eu to the uk so it
wasn't an oven ready deal and we could
be having a trade war in july
if i had longer we could talk more about
it but yeah i think i think
i think it highly unlikely but i think
there's if i may say i think some i've
talked to some of our friends
uh here today who who do who do seem to
misunderstand
that the uk is a single country in a
single
uh territory and they i think they just
need to get that into their head
india indian variant locking down delay
look i know you're making a decision on
monday but the indian variant the
transmission is at 60 percent
higher than the kent variant and the
figures are not looking good are they
it's clear that the indian variant is
more transmissible
and uh it's also true that the cases are
going up and that the levels of
hospitalization
are going up now we don't know exactly
to what extent that is going to
uh feed through into uh extra mortality
uh but clearly it's a matter of serious
serious concern now less optimistic
from where you were at the end of may
that's fair isn't it yes
that's certainly fair and what we want
to do is make sure that the roadmap
is irreversible but you can't have an
irreversible roadmap unless you're
prepared to be to be cautious some of
the data is still open to
to question but we'll be making a an
announcement on
on monday uh in all in all the details
that you could
it's all pretty depressing to be honest
isn't it i mean
can you do this at least can you re
assure our viewers
that your cautious but irreversible
route out of lockdown where we've got to
now the may
17th unlocking we're not going back can
you just
guarantee us that i think that all our
viewers
uh should be reassured by this that the
situation
is dramatically different from what it
was
in either of the the first two waves of
the of the pandemic and
and yes it is absolutely correct to say
that
you've got cases going up now from the
the delta variant and you you've got an
increase in hospitalizations
but you're seeing a different group now
going into
hospital largely and
the outcomes on the whole are better
but but and
that is caused by the huge effectiveness
of the vaccine
rollout so so you you'll see what you're
seeing
that we are not going back we won't be
going back to taking the kids out of
school we're not having any more
lockdowns it's done
the whole point of having an
irreversible
roadmap is just that to make it
irreversible
and to do that sometimes as i've said
repeatedly
you have to be cautious and where it's
necessary to be
to be cautious we will do so
just to cheer you up a little bit more
and what i can tell you is that the
scientists are agreed about one thing
that they do not
think there is any case for going into
reverse
so what we're looking at is
uh yes absolutely an increase in
in cases we're seeing an increase in
hospitalizations
but the context has radically changed
because of the sheer
number of people who have been
vaccinated and particularly
the the elderly and vulnerable so the
objective now
is to give that vaccination program
the legs the impetus the speed it needs
to to beat the the spread of the virus
and i've got no doubt that it can
you